we progressed from a state of Simplicity  to a state of Randomness and complexity  quite abruptly technology allowed us to  connect with each other and stretch our  cognitive limits in unprecedented ways  we thought that we would improve every  aspect of our experience but in reality  we started to lose our minds once you  understand this don't be hard on  yourself don't fight it don't get mad  don't despair don't worry about feeling  then uncomfortable instead understand  that feeling uncomfortable should be  viewed as a virtue not a hindrance the  key here is to realize the necessity of  this stage view it the same way you view  adversity and growth since adversity is  a necessary ingredient of growth allow  it to train you and strengthen your  mental resilience for it probably  constitutes the most imperative stepping  stone to reaching what one so  desperately desires extreme  self-awareness and extreme  self-ownership